Jennifer starts off this hour in Philly
hey Jennifer welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show thank you how are you better than I
deserve what's up in your world right
now having some issues with my student
loan I currently all $121,000 but I was
on a payment plan things got messed up
and so basically I have now working with
a company who's taken over my student
loans they asked me to make a good-faith
payment and they said even if I make it
I would still have to go to court with
them so I was wondering so I make the
kid faith payment even though they're
still gonna sue me or what I should do
because I understand at all okay so
these are not federally insured student
loans these are private these are tied
again yeah okay and how much do you owe
the particular ones that they has been
turned over to an attorney hundred and
twenty one thousand dollars one hundred
and four principle and one loan yeah I
consolidated it um a few years ago
because it was been excused Eero for my
life to make payments a lot of stuff
that stuff happens and I said the best I
could and unfortunately I couldn't pay
them what is your degree in I have an
undergrad bachelor's degree of Arts and
International Studies and public
relations and advertising and
ambassadors and student Personnel
administration so basically I can work
on the college campus for the rest of my
life uh-huh well or not yeah the so what
do you make what's your income right now
it's 35 I've been trying for the last
five to ten years in the field to move
up from making money however my housing
is public because I oversee resident
pulse so I don't have to pay for
utilities or housing it's really just my
bills yeah you don't make enough money
yeah and you have the ability to make
double or even triple what you make now
with a degree in publicity and
communications you're no longer in the
college world the college world is not
treating you well now it's time for you
to start looking for a job okay because
if you could make seventy five thousand
dollars a year you can address this loan
issue it's gonna be very difficult to
address at thirty five thousand and
you're stuck you need to get unstuck you
mentally and emotionally you're stuck on
this College thing and it's killing you
you've got to get out yeah all right I
got PR people working on my team the
most junior of them makes more than you
that doesn't doesn't have a master's
degree and has zero experience and just
crawled off the college campus on their
hands and knees and they make more than
you you get out there and scratch around
kiddo you're worth a lot more than
you're being paid okay and cuz that's
not your issue you don't make enough to
address a hundred and twenty six
thousand dollar debt making thirty five
thousand dollars a year we got to get
your shovel up you're in a bigger hole
wrong yes are you gonna do something
about it
no um I've been job searching trying to
find jobs that pay more but within my
field but I'll branch out and see if I
can do something different well me the
PR and publicity is your field isn't it
it is you can make more in that than
that then you're being paid right now in
that field well we're sure for sure and
you know you've just got a how old are
you 33 yeah yeah okay yet you just got
you got sidetracked off on a bad track
here that's not working for you
financially and it's gonna make you
reset your goals and I guess because
they were furnishing housing and it was
easy and you know think about it did you
just got down on a rut and so I'm
kicking you up out of that rut you have
to have a new job by Christmas do you
hear me I'm gonna send you a copy at Ken
Coleman's book the proximity principle
to
you get something landed and then you'll
be able to address this as far as
whether to let them sue you it doesn't
matter you can either pay them or they
can sue you
it's an unsecured loan it's not a
student loan it technically is called a
student loan but basically it's not
going federal government intervention or
guarantees or anything else in the
processes so this is a private lender
that you are in default to they've
turned it over to an attorney you can
work with the attorney and come up with
payments that you can pay by working
extra jobs which is what I recommend or
they will sue you and eventually they'll
get around to garnishing you so I spent
all my time talking about your income
with you but because that is going to be
the answer you start sending them a
thousand two thousand dollars a month
because your income goes up this lawsuit
goes away they're not they're going to
be just smiling and cashing your checks
then but the problem is you've not been
mathematically able to address the
situation and so you're getting sued
that's what it comes down to and you've
got to change the math